there's a kind of Golden Rule of
protesting it's a pretty easy one to
remember don't be a dick I think that
social media companies for a very long
time have lived in an absolute fantasy
where they've printed money from thin
air by charging people for pixels her
voice drips with the same password that
the voice of Kamala Harris drips with
he said in January uh just before the
pandemic began that we were fully
prepared as a country for the pandemic
after the first reports from China had
come out about a coronavirus turned out
we were uniquely ill-prepared we had no
PPE equipment which meant that a lot of
health workers and care workers died we
had no testing system which meant we
didn't know who the hell had at any
given time so we sent elderly people
back from hospitals into Care Homes
where they died in their tens of
thousands we didn't close our borders at
all we let millions of people flood in
from countries where coronavirus was on
the Rampage
etc etc etc on vaccines it was Kate
Bingham who sorted out the vaccines not
Matt Hancock
when you put the case for this I'm sure
the pandemic Diaries will tell a
different story but I was living all
this all day every day and I will be
fascinated to read his account of it but
the idea that somehow before was even
been an inquiry we should be letting him
off the hook when the the UK had and
this Remains the case more people die in
the UK from covid than any other country
in Europe that's just a statistical fact
your Elon Musk this idea of charging
eight dollars now a month uh whatever it
is to access the Blue Tick premium
Twitter account would you do that would
you pay the extra
I think that social media companies for
a very long time have lived in an
absolute fantasy where they've printed
money from thin air by charging people
for pixels and they grew into these
large conglomerates with too many staffs
sitting around doing nothing having
coffee breaks and Elon Musk is a
businessman he's walked into the office
and he's firing a bunch of people who
are messing around doing nothing and he
wants his business to make money as it
absolutely should and how he decides
that happens is his prerogative I don't
see why we should sit and accept that
our website needs 200 000 people sitting
around discussing in Long meetings
sitting on beanbags about policy of
human rights of some garbage when he's
come along and said no I'm a businessman
we're going to charge for our service
we're going to reduce the number of
Staff we're going to be a functional
coherent company as they should be and
that's his prerogative to do it as he's
bought the company I think he can do
whatever he wants what did you make of
that Jordan to be suddenly appearing on
Meghan markle's podcast as a villain the
first thing I'm calling women crazy is
yeah well the first thing I make of it
is that her voice drips with the same
falsehood that the voice of Kamala
Harris drips with it's this
sanctimonious
um faux compassionate talking down to
her audience and trying to be sure that
we're all really on the same
compassionate page here and we're all
being victimized by terrible forces that
are arrayed against us none of that's
really fair and it's it just grates on
me and I do believe that it is the case
that it's very difficult to control
female anti-social Behavior often of the
type that's being pilloried as
hysterical and I think that there is no
shortage of clinical evidence to support
precisely that
um claim it's very difficult for women
to control female anti-social behavior
and females who are anti-social that
feminine pattern is reputation salvaging
under the guise of Compassionate Care
and it's it's extraordinarily
destructive the rights of protest is
fundamental to any democr could see
we've got every right to make demands of
the people who are supposed to service
and every right to make a nuisance when
they don't protest movements gave us
civil rights gay rights to female vote
they shape the Free World that we live
in today there's a kind of Golden Rule
of protesting it's a pretty easy one to
remember don't be a dick
just as you have a right to protest
everybody else has the right to go on
living their lives because the chances
are they're not the people that you're
protesting about the brats from just
stop oil have forgotten that Golden Rule
they seem to be taking great pride and
joy in causing daily havoc and misery
for British commuters by shutting down
motorways and in some cases the
consequences have been appalling first a
police officer was injured and two
lorries crashed trying to avoid a
roadblock and then came this
I was actually due to be a pallbearer on
my father's coughing along with my son
and we both got
that taken away from us there's nothing
that we could have done
someone that I don't know has taken that
ability for me to say farewell to my
father away from me
it's disgusting
he went on to say you'll never forgive
them and I don't blame him how could he
he had to ring his mother and say he
wasn't going to be there at the funeral
of his father where he was going to
carry the coffin and nor could he bring
his children
that man's grandchildren they all missed
the funeral
you can't do it again
what did he do wrong
to deserve that what do any of the
people who've missed work lost money
missed very important medical
appointments what did they all do wrong
just stop oil wants more action on
climate change so do I
but they're the wrong victims and
they're going about this the wrong way
the point of protest is to put pressure
on the powerful to change calls to do
that you need to have public support
it's democracy that's why we have civil
rights gay rights and the female vote
but what kind of protests like this what
it does is to infuriate and irritate the
very people that is supposedly trying to
persuade it just stop oil wants anyone
to listen to them well let me give them
some very very simple advice
stop being dicks and he seems to think
in my view that he's going to be able to
reinvent himself like Ed Balls did who
is now a national Treasurer having done
strictly and some great television
programs but honestly Matt Hancock is
not Ed Balls people who know him say
he's actually quite likable
in my opinion you are the most
uncensored person I've had on the show
ruffling some feathers why aren't you
naked well I did hear your challenge but
I didn't think the public were quite
ready for that tell me very quickly what
is your protest about so the feather
speech campaign is science and artists
coming together to try to use
um common sense to save these amazing
Birds Swifts and three other red lips
listed species facing National
Extinction simple solution with the
petition but it needs a hundred thousand
signatures what's the answer the answer
is we can all help these Birds by
putting Swift bricks in our new houses
which is why I'm I have a petition which
is I what I want you to sign it
signing competition but also individual
people can help these Birds because the
RSP be fully supportive of this they
think you're doing a good thing how do
people sign the petition they go on
Hannah montana.com they go on your
Twitter yes they go online it is Morgan
I'm gonna post it sign the petition the
least we can do for this lady for a
peaceful protest you're not daubing
graffiti anywhere you're not chucking
soup on Van goghs you're just doing this
you're coming on Piers Morgan uncensored
as uncensored as any guest has ever been
I applaud the the the the I think The
Bravery of what you're doing and I'm
gonna is it this yeah no it's not gonna
be a swift
that's it from us keep it uncensored